I am from a small village outside of
mexicali baja california which is the
peninsula down south with our bordering
country Mexico
but I was growing up not in a million
years did I ever think that one day I
was going to be here sitting at this
wonderful institution right now sitting
in this beautiful room at Johns Hopkins
Bayview hospital doing what I do which
is brain surgery a combination of brain
surgery and science so not an indication
as I was growing up because I didn't
grow up with role models I didn't grow
up with people who are physicians
although now that I look back in my life
I tell you always try to look back and
try to run to send yourself a little bit
better he turns out that my grandmother
my fraternal grandmother was a town hero
she was also the the midwife for all the
people that actually you know grew up
with no access to modern health care so
she was already a health care provider
in the old ways as we were growing up in
Mexico so as I look back that had a very
positive influence in my life
he was very simple when I first came to
the United States all I was looking for
was just a better way better
opportunities just to put literally food
on our tables at the time the country
Mexico was going through a very
difficult time the bifurcation of
classes between the rich and the poor
was getting exacerbated the middle class
will disappear and we happen to be able
to lower portions of the middle class so
we really went down to the the in our
bifurcation of class got accentuated so
we really dip down towards the people
who really had a difficult time even
putting food on our tables so that was
really it was a simple decision when you
deal with hunger when things are not as
clear as they are for other people and
you have dreams and you have that
passion for exploration that passion to
make it better for you and your family
which I had as I was growing up nothing
was ever gonna stop me
I came in Italy as a migrant farmworker
I mean the only thing that my family
knew what to do as I was growing up and
what I heard is that our people came
from humble backgrounds and they came to
work in the United States as migrant
farmworkers when I first came in the
first job that I did were literally
pulling weeds with this very same hands
that now you know bridge the gap between
the operating room and the laboratory
and what we did at the time and what I
did just like many migrant farm workers
I literally pulled weeds pick tomatoes
pick the corn went out and work in the
fields as a migrant farm worker this was
a wonderful experience I tell you I mean
wonderful in many ways because what he
did is just taught me the value of hard
work the value of working as a team in
what we used to do back in the times we
used to work in these big machines that
were peeking tomato and we were picking
tomato we used to work in the fields
moving together as a team but I also
learned that life can be difficult that
people can actually treat you
differently just because of the stigma
that comes along with being poor and
uneducated and working as a migrant farm
worker and I remember my very early
experiences as a migrant farm worker
where people wouldn't even give me the
time of the day where they will look at
me as if I almost didn't exist not
really hurt my feelings and I not so
much because they were treating me like
that but because many times my fellow
colleagues my fellow human beings which
in my opinion many of them which were
probably smarter than I was were treated
the same way so that really began to
invigorate and began to give me the
passion and the vision to one day leave
the fields and move on from working in
the fields as a migrant farm worker to
not work in the field
as a precision sign